I hope that you also feel how hopeful
even as you may feel angry because you
have the power to make things better and
you have helped to make the entire
country feel as if this is something
that's got to change you've communicated
a sense of urgency that is as powerful
and as transformative as anything that
I've seen in recent years Barack Obama
delivers a powerful message of hope
amid the widespread outrage and protests
following the death of George Floyd to
those families who've been directly
affected by tragedy please know that
Michelle and I in the nation grieve with
you hold you in our prayers we're
committed to the fight of creating a
more just nation in memory of your sons
and daughters the former president
addressed the nation on Wednesday in a
speech that live streamed on his website
as part of his my brother's keeper
Alliance townhall series Obama launched
the organization in 2015 to address
persistent opportunity gaps facing boys
and young men of color in a lot of ways
what has happened over the last several
weeks is challenges and structural
problems here in the United States have
been thrown into high relief in some
ways as tragic as these past few weeks
have been as difficult and scary it
uncertain as they've been they've also
been an incredible opportunity for
people to be awakened to some of these
underlying trends and they offer an
opportunity for us to all work together
to tackle them to take them off to
change America and make it live up to
its highest ideals in his speech Obama
found a way to acknowledge the
significance of the current climate
while also finding the silver lining and
giving a nod to America's youth
sometimes I feel this fair
I just see what's happening with young
people all across the country and the
talent and the voice and the
sophistication that they're displaying
and it makes me feel optimistic it makes
me feel as if you know this country's
don't get better and he had this message
for young people of color I want you to
know that you matter I want you to know
that your lives matter that your dreams
matter you should be able to learn and
make mistakes and live a life of joy
without having to worry about what's
gonna happen when you walk to the store
or go for a jog or are driving down the
street or looking at some birds in a
park on Monday Obama penned an essay
addressing the nationwide protests
following the death of George Floyd a 46
year old Minneapolis man who died after
former police officer Derek Chauvin
kneeled on his neck for over eight
minutes according to court records
obtained by CBS Minnesota the three
other police officers who were fired for
their involvement in Floyd's death have
been charged with aiding and abetting
murder
additionally Minnesota Attorney General
keith Ellison has increased former
officer Chauvin murder charge to
second-degree murder the charges come
ahead of Floyd's memorial tributes which
will reportedly be held next week in the
three cities he lived in throughout his
life Floyd will be laid to rest after
the final service in Houston On June 9th
there is a change in mindset that's
taking place a greater recognition that
we can do better that's a direct result
of the activities and organizing and
mobilization and engagement of so many
young people across the country who put
themselves out on the line to make a
difference and so I just have to say
thank you to them it's very important
for us to take the momentum that has
been created as a society as a country
and say let's use this to finally have
anything
you